bạn tìm một bài viết của một nick
Facebook dựa trên kiểu mình biết được
cái nick đấy là nick nào rồi nhưng mà
mình rồi mình tra đây bây giờ sự bị chưa
kết bạn với bà ấy bảo chưa Tí nữa lại
muốn tìm một bài của bạn Liên đoàn này
có làm suốt ngày bình tòa này sẽ không
ra ngon giờ mình sẽ thử làm như sau Bấm
vào đây này
khi chọn chất vải vào blog copy đường
dẫn Dưới đây sẽ đi bạn lại đi trước để
tạo một cái đã vào đây mình sẽ chọn nghề
chọn xuống cho mọi người bất kỳ ngon Bạn
thấy trên đường sẵn ở đây nó sẽ lại có
dạng này Twitter sẽ đó là kết hợp một
đoạn Mã này không hiểu nhá là gì ngon
tôi sẽ rõ decode base64 bữa nay mình sẽ
copy về được copy Việt Hương Sẵn đây
Sang đây ăn gì tốt các bạn ở đây mình sẽ
Em thấy ở đây về sự ra toàn bộ máy đang
họ từ khóa YouTube ạ